dazu sagen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live oder in ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen
und da schauen wir heute auf ja wetter
deutschland denn teile des landes
versinken seit tagen im starkregen
gestern war es besonders thüringen
sachsen und bayern die betroffen waren
heute sind es teile von nordrhein
westfalen und von rheinland pfalz die
teilweise wirklich untergehen unter den
wassermassen
das ist eine auswirkung der klimakrise
ist das ist glaube ich nicht mehr zu
bestreiten
das ist mittlerweile common sense wie
man das so sagt also da sind sich alle
meteorologen und wetterforscher
klimaforscher einig aber die frage ist
was machen wir jetzt und wie kommt es
eigentlich dazu dass diskutieren wir
heute und fragen wir unsere zdf
wetterexperten und meteorologin katja
horneffer bei mir im studio halo hat ja
freut mich dass du da bist danke
außerdem sprechen wir am ende des teams
also zu gegen mitte mit professor jörn
birkmann der ist professor am institut
für raumordnung und entwicklungsplanung
an der uni stuttgart und der ist kein
experte genau dafür wie baut man städte
wie baut man häuser gebäude so um dass
sie diese klimakrise diese
klimakatastrophe bisschen besser
verkraften dass es auch für uns
erträglicher wird in der stadt zu leben
und wir schalten jetzt aber erst mal zu
unseren kolleginnen einmal gleich zu
ariane gödel die ist in erkrath hat
versucht nach hagen durchzukommen es war
aber überhaupt nicht möglich und wir
sehen uns hier schon im hintergrund und
wir beginnen damit gleich bei marion
geiger in rheinland-pfalz empfohlen wir
wollten erst marian anfang richtig
marianne liste mich ganz schlimm
ausmachen geiger ist in rheinland-pfalz
ariane geht die welt so ein bisschen
unter so sieht es zumindest aus ariane
wo stehst du jetzt gerade
wird eigentlich immer schlimmer in
erkrath ist heute die düssel über die
ufer getreten und dass sehr viele
menschen aus ihrem haus gerettet und in
sicherheit gebracht man es kommt immer
mehr wasser teilweise 200 liter auf den
quadratmeter
man sieht hier hätte mir die straße
verbindet sich hier das geht wie möglich
wird es schlimmer in einem kreis limburg
und die gummis von einfach diese
wassermassen gar nicht mehr auffangen
und das nicht nur hier sondern
eigentlich im ganzen land in düsseldorf
sind die evakuierungen wurden
unterführungen gesperrt in mettmann
überall gibt es probleme in abend noch
einen campingplatz geräumt weil total
eine talsperre vollgelaufen ist also
lang darunter in nordrhein-westfalen
kann man sagen gibt es schon der weg
hierher ist nicht ja genau das wollte
ich gerade fragen gibt es überhaupt noch
die möglichkeit da vorzudringen bis zu
euch oder kommt man dann einfach an
gesperrten straßen vorbei und kommt
überhaupt nicht mehr weiter kann
eingegeben empfehlen der nächstenliebe
zu hause die landstraßen gesperrt grunde
schalten sie aufhalten der autobahn
es bilden sich riesige wand salat es
kann doch einige unfälle die ich jetzt
gesehen haben auf der fahrt hierher ein
baum umgestürzt lag auf der rechten spur
warum also wer war gerade erst
umgefallen als er sich auf eine gefahr
wenn der boden so weit wird und dann die
bäume umstürzen also sehr mies aus muss
sollte lieber zu hause bleiben und kann
es mittels jahr haben getroffen heute
infektionen darüber sprechen aber
vielleicht kann ich kann dein kollege
dein kolleginnen an der kamera ich weiß
nicht wer dahinter steht vielleicht ein
bisschen mal schwenken und zeigen wie es
da so um euch herum aussieht weil das
ist von hier aus fast gar nicht wirklich
zu begreifen immer mehr wassermassen ja
auch immer mails haben wir eben
feuerwehren thw vorbei
er setze immer neuen einsätzen gerufen
werden also dieser lage ist dramatisch
und so ein tier und für die menschen die
unmittelbar betroffen sind
da stellt sich in der graz ein bisschen
die frage du hast schon du hast schon
hagen angesprochen warum sind die leute
überhaupt noch auf der straße ist dem
nicht klar dass das jetzt langsam
brenzlich fühlt sich durch diese
wassermassen zu bewegen sich innerhalb
von wenigen stunden dramatisch
entwickelt sie haben das heißt heute
morgen sah bei dem noch nicht ganz so
schlimm aus und ärgert sich hierzu
geschnitzt dann lasst uns vielleicht
crossover haken sprechen da haben wir
auch aktuelle bilder und das ist
wirklich schrecklich was wir dort sehen
die kollegen können das gleich mal zu
spielen erzählt auch mal was ein haken
passiert ist ja die ja die menschen die
dort leben
wie hast du den schwer getroffenen mit
einigen stadtteilen dort sind eben auf
abhängige ins rutschen gekommen ganzen
autos mitgerissen worden
dass die situation dort nicht aufhören
oder haben sich ganze auch gerade
interne
oder erpfingen entwickeln sich die
straßen zur wahren sturzbächen und die
menschen sind wirklich arm dran weil es
ihr wirklich gucken wenn sie ihre häuser
und weil es nicht mehr weitergehen soll
weiter regnen
zumindest in hagen auf bis mitternacht
dann so dass immense abebben
insgesamt soll es morgen besser werden
aber noch müssen wir mit regen rechnen
und das ist nicht ohne und nicht
ungefährlich das sind ganz schön kassel
bilder in erkrath war auch zu hören gab
es jetzt die bitte der stadt dass man
nicht mehr das wasser und die
kanalisation so benutzen soll wie
üblicherweise kannst du es noch mal kurz
erklären
ja man sollen möglichst fahren dann
damit umgehen oder auf toilette gehen
weil eben das haben wir hier auch und
damit nicht noch mehr wasser in die
kanalisation hineinfließt und die leute
aufgefordert werden möglichst nicht
abzuwaschen und keine wäsche zu waschen
und wasser zu sparen ja nichts gegen den
spanier und zu schicken
ach ja und dann danke ich dir und ich
hoffe dass du nach hause kommst trocken
wirst du es glaube ich heute nicht mehr
schaffen
bis hierhin erstmal vielen dank und wir
schauen uns mal an wie die
großwetterlage so in den letzten 24
stunden war das hat als die kollegin
claudia weiler zusammengefasst tief
bernd rollt über deutschland und trifft
in berlin direkt auf den fernsehturm
schäden gab es hier wohl nicht anders im
bayerischen hof katastrophenalarm
überstunden die wassermassen bringen
ganze mauern zum einsturz
stinkende brühe auch im schlafzimmer
hunderte notrufe die leitungen zeitweise
überlastet
manche anwohner versuchen sich selbst zu
helfen jetzt haben wir geschaut dass wir
zumindest ein bisschen die gullydeckel
befreien können in der hoffnung dass es
ein bisschen abfließt müssen wir gucken
wo es das hilft findet wieder rein und
weiter abwarten bis die feuerwehr oder
ähnliches kommt im sächsischen großstadt
bleibt es nicht bei sachschäden seit dem
abend wird ein mann vermisst die fluten
haben ihn wohl mitgerissen
die suche blieb bislang erfolglos
in hagen in nordrhein-westfalen stecken
sogar einsatzkräfte fest bei 1 meter 50
wasserstand ist autofahren unmöglich im
gegenteil nicht nur autos verschwinden
gleich ganz in den fluten mitgerissen
über die kreuzung hinaus auf andere
seite also alles was hier geparkt war
wurde mitgenommen
das unwetter und die schäden werden die
anwohner wohl noch viele tage
beschäftigen nicht nur hier in hagen den
tief bernd ist gekommen um zu bleiben
auch für die nächsten tage kündigt der
deutsche wetterdienst ergiebigen regen
an
besonders für den westen und süden von
deutschland wir sind echt dramatische
bilder und ich kann jetzt gerade nochmal
hier aus den agenturen berichten
die bundeswehr ist mittlerweile in hagen
teilweise der thw zur seite gesprungen
das heißt da wurde jetzt darum gebeten
dass unterstützung kommt und das wird
gemeldet dass in altena im sauerland
nordrhein westfalen ein feuerwehrmann
ums leben gekommen ist bei
rettungsarbeiten nach dem start gegen
also ein weiteres todesopfer der
vermuten ja dass es noch mehr gibt und
das schalten wir mal weiter zu machen
geiger die auch viel wasser im
hintergrund hat ist in rheinland pfalz
wo genau schließt werden
ich bin in dem kleinen ort lade das ist
im eifelkreis bitburg prüm und sozusagen
auch um mittendrin in diesem sehr großen
regengebiet also als hierher gefahren
sind hier über eine stunde nur durch
regen gefahren und hier schüttauf als
wird gar nicht mehr auf
ich bin an dem kleinen fluss nimmt es
den wind
die nims ist eigentlich nur 45 meter
breit hier normalerweise und jetzt sehr
breit über die ufer getreten wird sehr
viel wasser auch sämtliche zuflüsse zur
nimmt die kommen hier richtig brodeln
und gurgeln die hänge runter also hier
in diesem tal ist auch so eine akustik
als wird man irgendwie an dem geburts
wasserfall stehen
man kann richtig zu gucken dieses wasser
steigt das vorher jede halbe stunde um
einen weiteren halben meter hier den
flüssen nicht nur an der nimmt sondern
auch an den anderen flüssen hier in der
eifel im landkreis beprobt pommes verlag
guten stunde gut drei stunden
mittlerweile der katastrophenfall
ausgerufen worden
kannst du da auch bei einem kameramann
eine kamera firma bitten einzuschränken
weil das sieht ja wirklich sehr
beeindruckend aus dem verlies wenn du
sagst normalerweise ist es mir ein
kleines bisschen genau also christoph
kannst du bitte mal hinter der kamera
den fluss zeigen also die kamera
schwenken damit wir den fluss besser
sehen können
das kommt hier
um aus dem tal wir sind vorher die
kleine straße entlang getragen haben uns
die orte weiter hinten angebracht da ist
das wasser auch ganz knapp unter den
brücken in den ortslagen da steht nur
sehr gewerbe unter wasser und als wir
dann zurück gefahren sind hierher in
dieser position sind wir auch auf den
straßen teilweise durch ziemlich tiefere
wasserlachen schon gefahren das hatte
sich also innerhalb von einer halben
stunde gebiet gebildet dieses wasser
dann sieht es wirklich auch in den
straßen dieser bergwärts herunterkommen
da haben die leute teilweise unten an
den straßen oder den seiten dieser
straßen so sandsack barrieren aufgebaut
weil eben auch über die straßen und über
die hänge das wasser hier zusammen läuft
im tal das heißt es steht zu befürchten
dass wir aus der region ähnliche bilder
bekommen wie jetzt
ausparken in der letzten nacht ich kenne
die bilder aus hagen jetzt nicht aber
was ich gehört habe
ich glaube der große unterschied ist
dass es hier natürlich deutlich
spärlicher besiedelt ist es ist ein
ländliches gebiet also die feuerwehr
fährt zwar auch sehr viele einsätze
wir sehen hier ständig feuerwehrwagen
vorbeifahren überall sind kleine
tröpfchen die sandsackwälle aufbauen die
keller leer pumpen
aber wir haben bisher hier aus dem
landkreis noch von keinen
personenschäden geführt und ich gehört
und deswegen denke ich dass die leute
hier vom wasser hoffentlich einfach
insofern verschont werden
als dann niemand zu schaden kommt
körperlich aber dieses viele wasser hier
aus der eifel also alle flüsse führen
hochwasser und dieses viele wasser das
wird natürlich dann ins tal fließen in
die
mose dort wird in hochwassers erwartet
wie es ungefähr so alle fünf bis zehn
jahre vorkommt das ist sehr sehr
ungewöhnlich dass es so ein hochwasser
im juli gibt normalerweise gibt es das
im winter aber im juli ist das extrem
selten und der deutsche wetterdienst
sagte er mir vorher ist hätte er jetzt
hier in der gegend am letzten tag so
viel geregnet wie sonst in einem ganzen
monat und es kommt eben noch einiges an
wasser nach es ist sehr schwer zu
prognostizieren wie hoch dieses
hochwasser letzten endes hier in den
kleineren flüssen ausfallen wird aber
die feuerwehr ist schon immer noch sehr
alarmiert und der einsatzleiter hier mit
dem ich vorhin gesprochen habt er hat
auch gesagt also so was hat er jetzt
noch nicht erlebt obwohl auch hier in
den letzten jahren die
hochwasserereignisse deutlich
zahlreicher aufgetreten sind als früher
in vielen dank ich habe mir eine frage
an ariane aus dem aus dem stream und
zwar möchte ein user wissen muss - hier
gab es schon reaktionen der nsd nrw
landesregierung auf das ja oft das
geschehen innenminister herbert reul hat
er sich geäußert armin laschet hat er
das gesagt hat ministerpräsident
auf der irgendwie und wälder jetzt ja
ja ich habe bestimmt gewesen hieß es
land unter geht man die regierung warnt
die menschen auf die straße zu gehen und
würden alle hilfe im einsatz
das ist das so sagen kann ja ich kann
sagen dass die kollegen vom wdr gerade
gemeldet haben dass sich armin laschet
morgen nach hagen bewegen wird und sich
vor ort ein bild der lage zu machen
und der will sich dort mit dem
oberbürgermeister und den krisenstaaten
über das weitere vorgehen austauschen so
weit jetzt also die lage vor ort ich
danke den beiden kolleginnen dieser
tapfer im regen stehen ich hoffe ihr
kommt heil und sicher irgendwann nach
hause und wir sprechen jetzt genau über
die ursache für das ganze mit katja
horneffer unserer meteorologin und
wetter expertin katja ich kann dir schon
mal sagen hier im chat ist wieder
einiges los ich rufe sie auf youtube
da gibt es viele menschen die ich sag
mal etwas zögerlich sind der
einschätzung zuzustimmen dass der
klimawandel die klimakrise diese
wetterlage verursacht hat das kannst du
dazu sagen also dazu kann man sagen dass
die gesamte klimaforschung sich einig
ist dass im zuge der globalen erwärmung
extremwetter wie diese die wir jetzt
gerade erleben einfach häufiger werden
also wir hatten ja in den letzten drei
sommern unheimliche hitze
das war ein extrem und dieses ist ein
anderes extrem und es gibt dazu noch
mehr zu sagen wir haben ja moment eine
wetterlage dieses tief mitteleuropa das
ist viel häufiger geworden und man hat
das beobachtet der deutsche wetterdienst
hat das untersucht dass solche tiefs
mitteleuropa in den letzten fünfzig
sechzig jahren häufiger geworden sind
und diese genau diese wetterlagen sind
ja eben für unsere hochwasser
verantwortlich das war auch in den
vergangenen jahren mal so wenn wir
hochwasser hatten ich denke an 2002 und
ähnliches 2016 das war dann immer ein
tief mitteleuropa und dass diese
wetterlagen häufiger werden das kann man
eben erklären das hängt ganz eindeutig
mit dem klimawandel zusammen da gibt es
ja auch die sache mit dem jetstream wird
hier auch schon angesprochen klären wir
gleich
wie ist denn das dieses konkrete tief
eigentlich entstanden bernd eilers sorry
an alle bands da draußen die sich jetzt
nur sprüche anhören müssen das wird aber
ja zufällig vergeben wie das tief jetzt
heißt wie ist es jetzt so weit gekommen
eigentlich ist erstmal ganz normales
tief gewesen das vom atlantik
herangekommen ist aber dieses tief
konnte da nicht weiter ziehen wir hatten
eine art von blockierender wetterlage
und dann hatte sie sich richtig
eingenistet über südfrankreich und über
dem alpenrand man kann dieses tief bernd
eigentlich als ein tiefdruckkomplex
bezeichnen soll heißen kleinere tiefs
kleineren teams entwickeln sich daran
immer gerade heute das was die
kolleginnen eben berichtet haben dieser
kräftige regen in nordrhein westfalen
das war so ein kleines tief das eben von
niedersachsen über nordrhein westfalen
dann weitergezogen ist in diesem großen
tiefdruckkomplex drin ist wir sehen hier
glaubend und hier sehen bester ist bern
ja bernd also das zentrum von bernd das
siehst du vielleicht da unten im
äußersten süden deutschlands weiter und
noch genauso richtung bodensee so und
jetzt was du siehst dieses hier ist ein
radar und satelliten film von den
letzten 12 stunden sieht man halt wo es
am heftigsten geräten kannst du siehst
die ist jetzt gerade hier in
niedersachsen heftiger wird und dann
nordrhein westfalen also vor allen
dingen bonn betroffen köln das
ruhrgebiet und so weiter so genau die
region auch da wo wir gerade hin
geschaltet haben auch in der eifel und
das wird natürlich auch noch dadurch
verstärkt dass wir da gebirge haben das
natürlich dann das wasser die wolken da
gar nicht gut weiterziehen können und
dann gibt es diese enormen regenmengen
auf engem raum was ich mich da immer
frage so als totaler wetterlage
irgendwann ist doch mal zu ende geregnet
wo kommt denn das ganze wasser her also
das muss doch irgendwann kennt man ja
irgendwie dass die wolke alle und dann
ist wieder einmal so eine schwere schön
ist aber nicht so und das liegt daran
dass sich dieses tief immer wieder
regenerieren kann das schon auf die
warme und feuchte luft aus richtung
mittelmeer ein und gleichzeitig kommt
die kalte luft von der nordsee dazu und
dann muss diese warme luft auf die kälte
auf gleiten und dann haben wir diese
enorm hohen wolken die ganz schwierigen
mitbringen und da das tiefste ich die
ganze zeit drehe kannst dir vorstellen
wie so eine schleuder eine waschmaschine
keine
und was kommt immer wieder was nach an
nachschub und deswegen schüttet ist so
ergiebig wir haben jetzt hier mal im
hintergrund was werden noch erwarten bis
samstag da sieht man die region die es
noch mal besonders treffen wird also
gesamte westen und süden deutschlands
mit noch mal 30 bis 100 liter pro
quadratmeter
jetzt haben uns gerade haben wir gerade
diese corona karten sind los diese regel
kaum bewegen kann
diese war im hinterland ja so und das
heißt 100 liter pro quadratmeter
genau wie viel stunden entfielen das ist
jetzt bis samstag ja und wir hatten
jetzt ich habe noch eine andere grafik
mitgebracht da sieht man mal was heute
allein in köln gefallen ist und mich
fast 100 liter und in anderen städten in
nordrhein westfalen auch also wir hatten
jetzt oft tagesmengen von 70 bis 80 zum
teil auch an die 100 liter pro
quadratmeter das ist genau so hat das
auch eben die kollegin gesagt vollkommen
richtig mehr als man in einem ganzen
monat erwarten dürfte ja die größten
regenmengen wir jeweils hatten in
deutschland das waren in wenigen tagen
400 liter regen pro quadratmeter
es war damals bei dem bei dem
elbehochwasser
und das können wir jetzt wahrscheinlich
auch bald wieder erreichen also
regenmengen die rekorde brechen ich sehe
jetzt hier auch kommentare so von
frankie zum beispiel der meint das
wetter wird die wahre herausforderung
dieses jahrhunderts für die menschheit
mit cupid werden wir zwar genauso leben
lernen müssen aber im gegensatz dazu ist
klima noch mal schwerer in den griff zu
bekommen
jetzt hast du noch eine grafik
mitgebracht die hat sich die heißt omega
omega wetterlage weil waren natürlich
obwohl es ein ziemlich fette steve ist
dass wir hier sehen
das ist sowas wie diese omega wetterlage
das ist was wir da an orange sehen ist
dieser berühmte jet über den sprechen
wir später noch dieses hier ist eine
umgedrehte omega wetterlage weil der jet
sowie ein umgedrehtes großer griechische
buchstabe omega aussieht deswegen
sprechen wir von einer umgedrehten omega
wetterlage ebenso richtiger sumpf über
mitteleuropa das ist das tief
mitteleuropa dass sich immer wieder
regenerieren kann wie ich eben gesagt
habe flankiert von zwei hoch das übliche
was wir normalerweise unter einer omega
wetterlage verstehen ich glaube die
grafik haben wir auch da kann man
nämlich sehen dass wir normalerweise so
was haben das hatten jetzt in den
letzten sommern das war ich genau das
gleiche nur dass das hoch
bei uns lagen und wir deswegen die
extreme dürre hatten und die trockenheit
und die extreme hitze genau ja also das
ist tatsächlich ein problem kann man
jetzt sagen
es löst sich irgendwann auch ich meine
da kommen jetzt zum gestrigen rechnete
sich dafür sorgen soll dass so was nicht
dass er genau also haben wir das auch
noch im studium gelernt wir haben gesagt
haben gesagt also eigentlich ist es das
übliche bei uns dass die tiefs von west
nach ost über uns hinweg fliegen und ich
glaube wir haben dazu auch noch mal eine
grafik da kamen nämlich ganz schön sehen
wie hier kommt sie glaube ich gleich
genau da sieht man am äquator es ist
sehr warm über den pol kalt und zusammen
mit der erddrehung bewirkt das einfach
sehr starke westwinde und diese
westwinde das ist genau der jetstream
und das ist sowas wie die leitplanke für
hochs und tiefs
sie wissen also ganz genau hier geht's
lang ich rauche immer von west nach ost
über uns hinweg aber nun hat man
festgestellt in den vergangenen 20
jahren dass dieser 'dead immer mehr
melandri hat also so beulen kriegt er
schwächelt er schwächelt genau er wird
langsamer und damit können sich eben
tiefs tatsächlich mal wo festsetzen wie
jetzt aktuell das tief bernd über den
alpen oder wie ist das jetzt entstanden
wissen wir dass schon warum der diese
extreme jetzt das weiß man schon leise
man geht davon aus das ist eben
klimawandel das hast du ganz am anfang
vor kam richtig gesagt dadurch dass es
immer wärmer wird auf der erde dass es
immer heiß da wird auf der erde schmilzt
das eis der arktis
wenn das eis in der arktis schmilzt dann
ist natürlich dort nicht mehr so viel
weiß nicht mehr eis sondern eben der
offenen ozean der ist dunkel wir haben
einen sich selbst verstärkenden prozess
das heißt das schmelzen wird immer noch
beschleunigt und weil es da oben so heiß
ist und damit der druckunterschied
zwischen dem polen und zb dem bekannten
autor noch immer geringer wird der jet
so hin und her man konnte bis vor zwei
jahren nicht nachweisen dass das
tatsächlich auswirkungen auf unser
wetter hat man hat das jetzt inzwischen
erforscht über den umweg der
stratosphäre macht diese erwärmung in
der arktis tatsächlich die stratosphäre
ist ja in zehn kilometern höhe macht
genau das dass der jet schwächelt
häufiger solche blasen bildet und es
dann häufiger solche extremwetterlagen
gibt was ist das immer viel vom gleichen
und das ist immer ganz unangenehm
in der atmosphäre übrigens nicht dass
hier noch kurz als exkurs sagen darf hat
letztlich auch was zu tun mit den
waldbränden in nordamerika auch da ist
der jet ganz anders als üblich und so
hängt eben global alles miteinander
zusammen und genauso wie wir beim corona
virus bei weil genauso wie wir beim
corona virus nur eine gesamt welt lösung
finden können ist das eben halt auch
beim klima da ist da sind die bilder von
den waldbränden in nordkenia und kann
das ist dann ja das entgegensetzte
problemen nicht zu viel wasser sondern
zu wenig wasser so das heißt alles ist
in teams ungleichgewicht geraten
wenn wir davon erzählt sieht man so ein
bisschen den leuten in deinen augen bis
fast ein bisschen so fasziniert davon
habe ich das gefühl
nein gar nicht man kann event ist aber
man es verstehen gehören und ich glaube
dass auch alle unsere zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer unsere user und userinnen das
verstehen können es ist eigentlich ganz
einfach und wenn man dann immer wieder
hört menschen die sagen ja ich glaub da
nicht dran oder klimawandel gibt es doch
gar nicht dann denke ich mir immer
schaut euch das an
es ist es die forschung sagt das eins zu
eins oder auch auf eine schlimme art
schon faszinierend die das alles
miteinander zusammenhängt so dass man
sich so ein bisschen damit also das ist
schon wieso eingewiesen system aus dem
gleichgewicht gerät und dann irgendwie
alles miteinander mitreißt ja das
schlimme daran sehe ich eher dass wir
dass wir eben die altlasten der letzten
jahre mit uns mitschleppen also wir
können das ja nicht einfach umdrehen wir
können ja nicht sagen jetzt verhalten
wir uns alle ganz wunderbar schön und
übermorgen hat der jet wieder seine
normale bahn ja das ist eigentlich das
faszinierend schlimme daran das wäre
tatsächlich jetzt auch eine frage
gewesen die hier gerade ich glaube
vorfahrt geschrieben hat vorfahrt hat
auch gerade schon kommentiert wie er in
der schule darüber gesprochen heute und
man hat schon in den 60er jahren vom
klimawandel gewusst aber die oft
gefahren herunter gespielt jetzt hat uns
etwas eingeholt und er oder sie kann ich
nicht sagen möchte wissen kann man auch
noch in wie umkehren kann man den
jetstream wieder zurückholen
also wir können natürlich alle irgendwas
tun das ist ja ganz klar jeder kann
seinen eigenen beitrag leisten und in
der summe sind wir dann viele und was
wir bewirken können sieht man ja auch
wieder an corona
schon da die eier stellen na ja also es
war früher schon solche mega wetterlagen
gab es auch schon viel früher ja nur
dass sie sich so häufen ja das ist eben
das ungewöhnliche und natürlich ich sag
dazu immer gerne allgemeinen das
wohlverhalten hat noch nie geschadet
also natürlich muss sich jeder an seiner
nah an seiner eigenen nase fassen aber
es ist natürlich auch auf jeden fall die
politik gefordert ja so peter welz kopf
möchte dass ich mich ins kind herren
sind verabschiedet weil er das niveau
gruselig der tut mir leid peter kann es
auch gerne woanders hin schalten wir
versuchen das hier so ein bisschen
niedrigschwellig zu machen damit alle
mitkommen wir haben ja durchaus
zuschauer innen die noch nicht seit 30
jahren sich mit diesem thema
beschäftigen so katja vielen dank
erstmal wir kommen nachher nochmal zu
dir zum wetter jetzt möchten wir aber
erst mal mit jemandem sprechen der sich
mit der frage beschäftigt wie können wir
eigentlich ja dafür sorgen dass in den
städten das ganze besser abläuft dass
wir dort das erleben können denn wir
sehen ja das ist gerade ein problem und
das ist professor jörn birkmann
professor am institut für raumordnung
und entwicklungsplanung an der uni
stuttgart hallo herr professor bergmann
hallo sind sie überrascht von diesen
bildern jetzt zum beispiel aus hagen wo
die ganze stadt unter wasser steht
yahia topografisch bewegt da muss man
nicht davon ausgehen dass das was
irgendwann in der länder und der ruhe
ankommt muss man sich überlegen ob man
da vorsorgekonzept entwickeln könnte
oder auch kann in zukunft vielleicht
eine anmerkung ich bin auch koordiniert
auto im weltklimarat in der
arbeitsgruppe 2 und wir fragen uns eben
gerade was auch diskutiert wurde
wie kann man verhindern dass solche
extremwetterereignisse extreme
auswirkungen haben und da spielt zum
beispiel dann die strategische
stadtentwicklung die vorsorge
versicherungsschutz funktionieren des
thw spielen eine rolle aber es reicht
eben nicht hinterher nur eine app zu
bekommen oder eine nachricht es kommt
jetzt ein starkregen sondern es muss im
grunde zehn jahre oder fünf jahre vorher
beginnen mit der vorsorge
das heißt vorsorge jetzt man wir uns
wirklich meinen konkreten beispiel
benennt was heißt das wenn nicht
stadtplaner bin wenn ich dafür sorgen
muss dass meine stadt sicher ist worauf
muss ich dann da achten
als ich dann hat sie am hochwasserschutz
gesehen egal ob es jetzt am rhein sind
in der nähe von düsseldorf
oder in hagen bereiche oder länder oder
hier in baden württemberg da ist
natürlich viel passiert da hat man
hochwassergefahrenkarten ich glaube beim
starkregen sind wir noch nicht so weit
weil vielfach die stadtplanung
angenommen hat dass diese wolken die ja
vorhin beschrieben sich über abrechnen
können das heißt da ist kein
spezifischer raum den sie schützen
können trotzdem wissen wir wenn man es
jetzt die schadensmeldungen angucken
oder auch die überfluteten unterführung
hier in haro in stuttgart oder in
bitburg sehen natürlich schon es gibt
bestimmte neuralgische punkte auch
krankenhäuser kindergärten sowas kann
man natürlich vorher schon planerisch
erfassen und überlegen wie kann ich dann
wassermassen zum beispiel in hagen ist
ein guter oder wuppertal ist ein gutes
beispiel über die straßen ableiten dass
eben diese kritischen infrastrukturen
nicht voll laufen oder auch die bewohner
die bestimmte häuser haben die in
starkregen gefährdeten gebieten liegen
dann auch ja nicht aufgefordert aber
zumindest informationen bekommen um sich
besser zu schützen das heißt sie wollen
jetzt entschuldigen sie das wortspiel
die straßen als wasserrutsche benutzen
ja es wird wahrscheinlich so sein dass
man nicht die kanalisation überall so
aufbauen kann wir haben selber forschung
gemacht hier mit der stadt schwäbisch
gmünd wo ja auch erhebliche zwei
todesopfer in 2016 entstanden sind
dort hat sich gezeigt dass eben die
kanalisation alleine diese wassermassen
nicht ableiten kann und dementsprechend
es eben wichtiger ist dass über die
straßen oder auch grünen bereich also
wenn es an die stadt tagen denkt die hat
ja auch grüne züge und da ist natürlich
dann wichtig dass man auch stärker
darüber nachdenkt nicht nur wo kann ich
mich erholen sondern kann auch dieses
starkregen wasser oder auch die vorsorge
gegenüber hitzestress über diese grünen
infrastrukturen in die der städte besser
abgeleitet werden der glaube man könnte
das mit der kreation ableiten ist glaube
ich das kam ja auch so leicht in ihrem
beitrag glaube ich kaum vorstellen
hier gibt es auch einen kommentar da
passt dazu von marvel peters auf
facebook kein wunder das wasser sucht
sich seinen weg bebauung immer schön
dicht an flüssen und bächen diese auch
noch mit steinen und beton begradigen wo
soll das wasser denn auch versickern und
dann passt dazu noch eine meinung die
ich noch mal hier zur diskussion stellen
möchte auch vielleicht mit katja diese
schäden sind keine folgen des
klimawandels sondern hirnlose
flussbegradigungen zubetonierte über
laufflächen trockenlegen von
feuchtgebieten und bebauung an falschen
orten und was dann übrig bleibt ist
minimales restrisiko zu
er ist die frage an den professor das
sehen sie auch schon einen punkt dass
dort in den städten falsch geplant und
gebaut wurden also man hat glaube ich
bei dem hochwasser thema in den letzten
15 jahren schon viel gemacht egal ob
köln nehmen oder die
hochwassergefahrenkarten
hochwasserrisikomanagement karten neben
seiner bitburg wenn es war ein big block
waren gibt es nicht nur gutes bier
sondern auch erhebliche waldgebiete das
heißt dass sich die starkregenfälle
angucken auch in braunsbach oder
schwedischen und da kommt immer viel
geröll da kommt immer eher der sedimente
also da müssen wir auch über andere also
ohne einzugsbereiche solcher
starkregenereignisse nachdenken und dann
eben vorsorge dort betreiben man kann
wahrscheinlich nicht alle häuser
irgendwie auf dem gebiet stellen wo kein
starkregen nieder rauschen könnte das
glaube ich ist auch der metrologie klar
das heißt wer keinen ort wo nicht
starkregen auftauchen könnte aber wir
können die stehen ja reduzieren warum
müssen einfahrt in richtung haus gehen
warum es in kellergeschosse plötzlich
zur wohnung umgebaut sein wo plötzlich
ein starkregenereignis sein kann warum
fahren leute in unterführungen wo
starkregen sich schon gesammelt hat wäre
es für die absperrung zuständig also
können da sehr konkrete maßnahmen machen
und vielleicht mal eine anmerkung wenn
sich ein haus kaufen egal ob in
stuttgart oder in düsseldorf oder in
hamburg das koste relativ viel und sie
brauchen bauantrag da wäre es schon eine
ganze gesicht wenn man dann natürlich
den bauherren oder beim umbau diese
informationen über starkregen
bereitstellt weil dann kann man agieren
hinterher kann man im grunde das ist
gebaut
hier ist eine frage die es auch nochmal
eine ihre richtung von flocken wie kann
man die sika fähigkeit von böden denn
verbessern sind die grundwasserspiegel
nicht auch gesunken also das haben wir
ja auch das problem tatsächlich ein orts
dann denkt der laie okay da ist der
grundwasserspiegel gesunken da müsste ja
platz sein für das ganze wasser wenn es
dann von oben kommt ja die wassermassen
beim starkregen sind ja so stark dass
vielfach diese ein sieg möglich ist dh
da ist je nach topografie anlage sie hat
mir vom bitburg oder von hagens jetzt
gesprochen
das ist topografisch bewegter raum da
wird das auch in diesen tagen abfließen
was wir gesehen haben zum beispiel bei
schwäbisch gmünd war dass man alte mühle
welche überbaut hatte in den letzten
dekaden und sich dann natürlich die
schaden schäden in diesen straßen
besonders gesammelt haben also da wird
dann schon oft anzuraten zu überlegen
kann man solche bäche nicht wieder
freilegen und dadurch dass starkregen
wasser glimpflich oder schadlos ab
also hier gibt es glaube ich schon
möglichkeiten auf der einen seite ist
wasser zu halten im raum aber natürlich
ist das auch mal die frage wie dicht
will man bauen wie stark man bodenschutz
oder freiraum schutz betreiben aber
sicherlich auch in der stadt stärker zu
denken welche rolle müssen zukünftig
grüne und blaue infrastrukturen
übernehmen ist sicherlich central hat er
jetzt sogar das wort von minimalen
restrisiko so ist das noch minimales
restrisiko und ich vermute das neinsagen
also ich möchte dazu verschiedene sagen
erstmal natürlich retentionsflächen für
flüsse sind natürlich immer wichtig
damit ich ein hochwasser eben nicht in
irgendwelche städte so richtig rhein
leite ja so dass man dass die dass die
flüsse die bäche möglichkeiten haben
sich auszubreiten wir meinen ja gerade
gesehen aber genau hat ja wenn da genug
platz ist und da ist nichts da sind nur
ein paar häuser oder scheunen dies nicht
weiter stört ist das natürlich ganz
wunderbar und natürlich ist es richtig
dass versiegelung und so weiter eine
große negative effekte hat aber wir
wissen auch da geht es untersuchung vom
deutschen wetterdienst dazu dass
tatsächlich starkregen überall auftreten
kann in ganz deutschland und es ist
genauso wie der professor gerade sagte
also natürlich kann man nicht völlig
ausschließen dass ein so ein stark ring
ereignis trifft aber ganz wichtig ist
auch dass eben halt dieses starkregen
ereignis von uns vernünftig vorhergesagt
ist so dass man sich wenigstens selbst
in sicherheit bringen kann dafür gibt es
die unwetterwarnung des deutschen
wetterdienstes und das ist dann die
aktuelle sache ich kann überhaupt nicht
verstehen wie menschen in eine
unterführung reinfahren können die die
zu sehen übertrieben ist auch das was
wir gerade hinter der kollegin gesehen
haben dass da leute durch weiß nicht 50
zentimeter hohes wasser ich verstehe es
nicht weil das ist eigentlich gesunder
menschenverstand der 1
da zeigen sollte dass man das nicht
machen sollte und dann möchten was
anderes sagen und zwar zu den
hochwasserereignissen wir haben jetzt in
den letzten jahren immer häufiger
festgestellt dass es häufiger so was
gibt und das was früher ein
hundertjähriges ereignis ist jetzt immer
mehr zu einem zehnjährigen ereignis wird
das heißt dass wir einfach mit solchen
großen regenmassen rechnen müssen
genauso wie wir ja auch jetzt die
letzten sommer so große hitze hatten
also dass die wiederkehr zeit von
solchen extremereignissen eben deutlich
zunimmt also es wird deutlich schneller
das wiederkommen aber kann man denn als
stadtplaner das ist jetzt auch noch mal
eine frage
herr professor kann man da irgendwie
tatsächlich auch sagen okay wir haben
hier ein erhöhtes risiko und wir müssen
damit rechnen dass zum beispiel in einem
sommer nicht mehr so und so viel liter
fallen sondern es werden aufgrund von
diesen veränderungen so und so viel
liter und dann müssen wir
dementsprechend reagieren geht das ja
klar also dafür gibt es ja diese
niederschlags klimatologie der deutsche
wetterdienst aber dafür kann man
bestimmt mehr zu sagen ja da ballern sie
den grundsatz auch im baugesetzbuch
vorsorge oder gesunde wohnen
arbeitsverhältnisse zu schaffen und da
steht auch zum beispiel die
klimaanpassung dazu die
hochwassergefahrenkarten die gerade
erwähnt werden die 100 gebiete sind
heute im grunde keine baugebiete mehr
dürfen nicht bebaut werden also dass man
schon strenger geworden aber es trifft
natürlich manchmal auch kleine gemeinden
die dann plötzlich sagen um einen
entwicklungs anspruch geht verloren wenn
ich plötzlich keine neuen baugebiete
mehr hat weil alles im hq 100 bereich
nicht auf der anderen seite ganz
interessant wenn man sich die
rechtsprechung anguckt und
oberlandesgericht düsseldorf hat
kürzlich in der klägerin recht gegeben
die gegen die stadt geklagt hat auch in
nordrhein westfalen die eben zu wenig
große kanalisation für starkregen
ereignisse im grunde vorgehalten hat
also da wurde der schaden musste der
schaden dann von der stadt als
planungsfehler auch bezahlt werden und
hier wird sich jährlich an dass man auch
dieses thema starkregen risikovorsorge
besonders verwundbare oder anfällige
stadtbereiche auch stärker in die
strategische stadtentwicklung
stadtplanung einbezieht und ist ja auch
jetzt so dass man auch instrumente hat
mit denen man beispielsweise wenn man
über stadt erneuerung nachdenkt oder
verschönerungen heute da geht es ja
vielfach augen grünbereich man kann auch
spielplätze oder fußballplätze als
retentionsräume für starkregen nutzen
bei grossen hochwassern sprechen
natürlich über viel größer
redaktionsräume dieser mittel oder
oberrhein für köln gebaut werden müssen
aber 14 cent fragen müssen wir glaube
ich werden ganz kurz erklären mit der
begriff hier schonmal retentionsräume
sind quasi die ausweichflächen ups
ausweich absehbar flächen ja eine frage
an sie professor beckmann von cool wir
sollten sie fragen inwiefern es
vielleicht helfen für die häuser ohne
keller zu bauen also dann kann der nicht
volllaufen
ja ist prinzipiell natürlich geschickt
aber es sollte da natürlich auch
irgendwo eine sinnhaftigkeit sein also
wir haben natürlich in deutschland
fahren gute beispiel dass keller
genehmigt wurden dann ist der tagebau
weiter gezogen da waren sich alle nass
aber prinzipiell ist es natürlich
wichtig dass leute auch wissen wo kann
diese starkregen ereignis her laufen
weil starkregen haben wir eben die
herausforderung wenn sie da an 15 ihr
nachbar haben der sein grundstück anders
gestaltet modellierte mauerbau landet
plötzlich das star der starkregen der
aus dem handel kommt oder vom gelände
kommt in ihrem grundstück das heißt also
hier ist diese kooperation aufklärung
sehr wichtig und sicherlich macht es
sinn also stadt bonn hat das gemacht
auch hier in baden württemberg und nrw
wenn man gerade wichtiger gebäude hat
große infrastrukturen schulen
krankenhäuser und man weiß da das könnte
in so natal lage oder doch könnten stark
ereignisse auftreten dann macht es
natürlich besonders viel sinn weise ein
krankenhaus zu evakuieren ist noch mal
deutlich schwieriger als eine
unterführung haben sie denn das gefühl
dass diese problematik wirklich bei den
städten und gemeinden schon angekommen
ist oder befinden wir uns da so ein
bisschen in wiso einer corona lage
anfang letzten jahres wo alle sagten oh
da haben wir ein problem aber jetzt ist
das problem schon da ich glaube es kommt
an aber es gibt natürlich auch andere
interessen nehmen so wie jetzt wenn sie
selber ein haus kaufen und sie haben die
möglichkeit das grundstück
bis was ich 70 prozent zu bebauen da
werden sie ja nicht sagen ich habe jetzt
eine was ich 800.000 euro bezahlt für
ein grundstück in stuttgart oder in
düsseldorf oder hamburg und baue jetzt
nur 50 prozent voll also hier muss man
einfach sicherlich auch sagen dass durch
diesen druck auch wohnraumschaffung
immobilienpreise heute auch diese
städtische handel einfach da sein muss
und man dann auch sagen muss okay ich
brauche jetzt für das thema hitze
anpassungen für das thema anpassung an
starkregen brauche ich einfach nochmal
eine stärkere sicherung auch von
bestimmten grünflächen oder in hamburg
bei infrastruktur mit der u-bahn diese
zusätzliche stufe die abhilfe schafft
davon dass das starkregen nicht in die u
bahn schächte eindringt also das sind
alles vorsorgemaßnahmen die muss man
sich dann auch was kosten lassen und ist
natürlich schwierig wenn plötzlich
kosten auftreten und diese ereignisse
kommen nicht wohl wenn sie dann kommen
dann ist die stadt eben auch wieder am
pranger
dementsprechend kann ich nur empfehlen
das ist ein zukunftsthema klimaschutz
muss man machen aber auch die
strategische klimaanpassung ich bedanke
mich dafür für diese einschätzungen und
da ist tatsächlich noch ein bisschen was
zu tun
vielen dank und schönen gruß nach
stuttgart so und katja ich habe hier
immer noch viele menschen die fragen was
machen wir denn jetzt klar du hast
gesagt jeder kann seinen kleinen beitrag
leisten
heute hat auch die europäische
kommission angekündigt dass sie möchte
dass keine verbrecher autos mehr ab 2035
zugelassen werden da sagen manche super
wird zeit andere sagen das kommt viel zu
spät aber jetzt mal abgesehen davon ist
jetzt die fragen der theologin können
wir dafür sorgen ich glaube die frage
kam unter anderem von frankie nähe von
nic ob es meteorologisch gesehen noch
die möglichkeit gibt den klimawandel so
zu stoppen so dass wir wieder
bedingungen wie vor diesen
extremwetterlagen haben lustigerweise
habe ich gerade zuerst ehrenwerter
lachen sind ja extremwetterlagen also
gibt es dann eine möglichkeit
also ich will es mal so sagen wenn wir
jetzt möglichst viel in sachen
klimaschutz machen
dann schaffen wir es vielleicht dass wir
die erhöhung der temperatur etwas
verringert dass wir eben nicht bei 152
456 grad landen sondern vielleicht nur
bei zwei grad
und wenn dir auf zwei grad landen dann
können wir mit diesen ganzen ergebnissen
viel besser das verhandeln als wenn wir
viel weiter oben landen
bei der temperatur gerade er noch fast
macht ja deswegen müssen wir halt uns
alle wahnsinnig anstrengend und die
politik auch es muss ein vernünftiger
anreize geben und jeder muss bei allem
was er tut sich überlegen ist das jetzt
klimaneutral kann ich damit wirklich gut
leben habe ich ein reines gewissen mit
dem was ich tue und wie ich mich
verhalte so und jetzt kommen wir mal zu
dem was wir denn noch nie haben nämlich
das wetter gehört also gucken uns erst
mal die nacht an und bei der nacht sieht
man noch mal wo es am kräftigsten regnet
das ist eben entlang des rheins bis
ungefähr zum schwarzwald gerade dort
könnten auch noch mal heftige gewitter
dabei sein und wie immer macht ja also
wir machen die nicht so sehr wir werden
dir was zeigen dann gucken wir da auch
hin
wir machen nicht diesen dass wir in die
kamera gucken und gleichzeitig vision
das machen andere genau und man sieht
auch dass es große
temperaturunterschiede gibt also rügen
wird nur ihre tropische nacht mit 20
grad und 9 grad am alpenrand morgen über
tag gibt es dann wieder kräftigen regen
und das eben vor allen dingen der süd
und in der westhälfte auch wieder
dauerregen die erwarten morgen über tag
allein schon wieder 60 liter pro
quadratmeter im nordosten merkt man
davon nichts da kannst vielleicht mal
ein kleines gewitter geben temperaturen
dort bis 29 grad im süden sind es 17 bis
24 grad
aber ich habe noch extra die aussichten
mitgebracht weil sie so ein bisschen
hoffnung geben zumindest mal für das
wochenende
denn man sieht dass es von nordwesten
allmählich schöner wird da gibt es ein
neues hoch ein azorenhoch namens dana
das dann vielleicht den tief bernd
tatsächlich verträgt das heißt glücklich
ist der oben im nordosten lebten
nordwesten genau der von der nordsee
kommt das hochgenaue und generell
nordosten bleibt auch ihr genau wisst
dann auch er schöner ist total ist
natürlich auch noch wärmer als der
nordwest gut aber erst mal haben wir
noch eine schwierige nacht vor uns
gerade im westen des landes wir hoffen
dass sich diese meldungen der letzten 24
stunden nicht noch häufen werden so
richtig positiv sind ferber leider
derzeit noch nicht wir beobachten das
ganze weiter für euch natürlich ständige
updates gibt es bei uns auch heute de
oder in der heute app die hoffentlich
schon längst geladen habe da gibt es
dann eine push meldung wenn du wieder
was spannend ist oder was wichtiges
passiert es außerdem sollte man auch
vielleicht noch mal sagen
ein unwetter waren eps sollte man sich
installieren oder vom katastrophenschutz
etwa 7 anderem nina gibt ja auch noch da
kann man einstellen wo man lebt und dann
gibt es jeweils eine push mitteilung
wirklich eine dringende bitte das jetzt
zu tun bevor es dann zu spät ist und ihr
in ein unglück rennt das hoffen wir
können wir dann damit vermeiden katja
vielen dank dass du heute dabei ist also
alles erklärt hatte ich danke euch für
die ganzen fragen für das zuschauen und
fürs mitmachen und wünsche allen
betroffenen eine halbwegs folgen acht
bis dahin bis zum nächsten live stream
macht's gut und tschüss